le haut karabagh petit comme un
département français
l'urss a décidé en 1921 d'attribuer
cette enclave chrétienne à l'azerbaïdjan
pays musulman mais la population de ces
territoires montagneux est
majoritairement arménienne
à force de tension les nationalismes se
réveille et en février 1988
un million de personnes manifestent à
erevan pour le rattachement du karabagh
à l'arménie deux jours plus tard des
dizaines d'arméniens sont massacrés dans
un pogrom hassoun gheit en azerbaïdjan
c'est le début d'un engrenage sanglant
une guerre ethnique qui mènera à quatre
cent mille arméniens et 800000 azéri à
être déplacés réfugiés pour éviter les
massacres et l'exil prend une tournure
encore plus dramatique
le 7 décembre 1988 un tremblement de
terre toute la région arménienne où se
trouvent les camps de réfugiés faisant
25 mille morts à plus tôt oui c'est vrai
il y a des problèmes ethniques je vais
en valais région les conséquences
personnelles des secours aux sinistrés
c'est sous vireur jolie somme aux
métiers du chalet tout de suite après
nous règlerons les questions nationales
entre l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan
mais la situation empire avec
l'implosion de l'urss
à partir de 1989 celle escalade
militaire et le blocus du haut karabagh
par l'azerbaïdjan sur le karabagh est
dans une situation de blocus depuis 70
ans
aujourd'hui c'est un blocus total et
quand on dit que le blocus est levé
c'est un mensonge avec la fin de l'urss
vient le temps des indépendances celle
de l'arménie en septembre 1991
mais la liesse ne peut faire oublier le
conflit la première épreuve qui attend
l'arménie nouvelle est une épreuve
politique
il s'agit en effet de régler la question
du haut karabakh
la montagne les combats feront rage
encore longtemps côté azéri et arménien
on ne compte plus les victimes parmi les
militaires et les civils
tout cela sous les yeux hagards de
soldats de l'ancienne armée rouge qui ne
savent plus à quel ordre obéir
soit on nous retire soit on nous envoie
des renforts mais nous laisser comme ça
ça n'a pas de sens finalement après six
années de guerre et près de 30000 morts
un cessez le feu est signé le 16 mai
1994 le haut karabagh s'est autoproclamé
république jamais reconnu par la
communauté internationale est
revendiquée par l'azerbaïdjan
sans accord pacifique de nombreux
accrochages meurtriers ont éclaté depuis
entre des ennemis qui ne désarme pas
bientôt trente ans que la région
redoutaient une nouvelle guerre
[Musique]